is there anything in the books that you
would say it's a pleasant surprise
something you just you know started
writing and and now you go wow that's
become a major thing and I never thought
it would happen sometimes characters
push to the forefront and become more
important than you thought they would be
I know I've been doing the the supernova
conventions in Brisbane and we're moving
to one in Adelaide and there are some
other people from the show here on on
that supernova circuit including course
Michelle Lena Headey was there also
Jerome Flynn who plays Bronn the
mercenary bronze a clear example of a
character that really grew in in the act
of writing I mean I I knew that I didn't
want Tyrion to die in the hands of Lysa
Arryn so I knew that someone had to step
forward and fight for his behalf when he
he demanded a trial by battle in book
one and I knew it was going to be one of
these to sell swords that Tyrion would
cleverly manipulate the the guys desire
for wealth but I actually had two guys I
had bran and a character named chicken
and it was almost flipping the coin
which one died and which one stepped
forward and bran was the one who step
forward and even at that point I thought
well maybe Tyrion will use him and
discard anymore
but you know I need him through the
mountains and then he proved useful
because it was someone a Tyrion could
actually talk to and then he started
talking back and he had some funny lines
and his personality kind of developed
and you know they're all like words that
you're typing as well that this isn't
two people at this stage like right
right this is words that I'm typing but
I don't know where they come from and
then of course when you get to show you
cast a wonderful actor like electrum in
it and he really makes that part his own
and suddenly the character even more
appealing I think it'd be fair to say
based on what you just said that you
don't write to a plan the writing more
just you know grabs you and and you just
sort of chase it yes no I I mean I dunno
where I'm going I know where the story
ends I know the fate of the principal
characters no I'm not going to tell any
of you but there is a considerable
amount that you discover in the process
of writing that's the fun of writing
actually I've talked about in many other
interviews about the two kinds of
writers they had the gardener and the
architect you know the the architect is
like an architect planning a building
when he plans a novel he he knows how
many stories is going to be and how many
windows it's going to have and how it's
going to be heated and what the roof is
made of and where the plugs are going to
be in each wall and etc etc and he works
all of that out and blueprints all of
that or outlines it in the case of a
novel before he drives the first nail or
writes the first sentence the gardener
digs a hole and throws in a seed and
sort of waters it with his blood and
hopes that something interesting comes
out now mine drew the gardener knows
certain things the gardener knows
whether he print planted a potato or
germanium but and it would be very
surprising if you plant a potato and a
germanium comes up but a lot is
discovered in the in the process I I
think all writers are some combination
of these two but they they tend
according to your personality to one
side or another and I'm much more on the
gardener side I am you know I think like
90% gardener as were somebody like JRR
tolkien who you know one of my literary
idols who started out writing Lord of
the Rings as a sequel to The Hobbit and
it grew considerably the tale grew and
the telling as he said as mine has